our next guest has shattered glass
ceilings and she has made history and
she's someone we're very proud to call a
wildflower which is people doing
incredible things that we want to
celebrate and highlight here on the show
when i heard her story i freaked out
watch this
[Music]
hi i'm lauren simmons at 22 years old i
made history by becoming the youngest
and the only full-time female trader at
the new york stock exchange i am a
southern girl from marietta georgia i
did not have a background in finance i
had no intention of making history i
just wanted to make my mom proud of the
first job that i got after college i
made my way to new york and was offered
a job at new york stock exchange i just
hope that my story will inspire the next
generation to help build a great future
for
themselves freaking out reading your
story
please welcome
someone they call the wolfette of wall
street lauren simmons
i'm so excited to meet you i did such a
deep dive on your story and
starting out you were studying genetics
because of your brother
um so you were drawn to a numbers game
like how
did you find yourself in the new york
stock exchange what what happened there
no linear pathway whatsoever i i went to
school for genetics i was in my senior
year writing my senior thesis and
realized this is not something i can
pursue because i wanted to alter dna and
it's illegal to alter dna only in china
and since i wasn't going to move to
china and i could not speak mandarin i
moved to new york which is the second
best city no i'm kidding but
new york is great and you know i went
and i really wanted to
numbers is a universal language and so i
said where can i be where i can use
numbers and
and and i ended up at new york
what i loved
and i really appreciated this too that
you said somewhere
like be open
to things maybe you haven't studied for
or thought where your life's trajectory
was going to go if a job offer comes
your way
that wasn't necessarily in your
wheelhouse be open to it is that true i
love that yeah be open opportunities i
think we get so fixated on like what our
plan abc is and i think the most growth
comes from people just stepping outside
of their comfort zone getting a little
uncomfortable and taking a position
taking a job that you would have never
thought of i mean i'm sure you have like
i like rolling i didn't think i ended up
here i could say that
it's true which is amazing at one time
you were the youngest full-time female
trader on the floor
one of the stories i loved was that when
you and the boys would go to the bar
afterwards how would you handle that i
was the only woman
on a floor with 250 men
and you know as a woman
with no other women around me you you
have to think of yourself and so a lot
of these meetings a lot of deals get
closed by going out and partying which
whatever they would pass around rounds
of tequila shots and i would tell the
bartender after the first drink fill it
up with water put some salt add a little
lime to it make it real and i just be
throwing back you know shots of water
god
i wish i had done that
because then your the second half of
your sentence was i didn't want to be
like the sloppy messy girl and i was
like
[Applause]
i spent most of my life being that girl
life of the party
[Music]
you